the UK foreign secretary David Cameron
has expressed concern Israel's actions
in Gaza May violate international law
they made the comments on Tuesday while
going before a parliamentary committee
for more on this let's bring in villam
Marx in London uh who's been watching
this for civilan what else did the uh uh
UK foreign secretary have to
say well he was facing questioning from
lawmakers essentially very soon after
coming into this role as foreign sec
foreign minister here in the UK he was
repeatedly almost from the outset asked
about the situation in Gaza and whenever
he was asked initially about Israel's
potentially legal compliance with
international law he was evasive
eventually he acknowledged that um you
know he did have reservations he
personally had concerns watching events
unfold in Gaza day-to-day and he made a
surprising
admission in all these cases you know
there's a question mark as to whether it
is in breach of international
humanitarian law and that's why you have
to go back look at the episode of what
in particular was bombed and then ask
yourself the a bunch of questions which
is what the lawyers do and they give you
that advice the advice has been so far
that they have the commitment the
capability and the compliance but on
lots of occasions that is under
question now Cameron did also call call
for more humanitarian aidid to be
delivered into Gaza through a variety of
Crossings into the territory he also
said that the UK supported further
humanitarian pauses but he once again
reiterated the British government's
position that they would like to see a
sustained ceasefire when asked what that
meant he explained he would like to see
Hamas unable in future to militarily
threaten Israeli
civilians all right thanks for that
villain we're go live now to Tel Aviv
what